بومي شركه امريكيه ناشئه تاسست منذ عامين
تساعد اي شخص على انتاج موسيقى فيه 30
ثانيه فقط تخيلوا ما عليك سوى تحديد النوع
والايقاع والالحان تقول الشركه عبر موقعها
الالكتروني انها انتجت حتى الان ما يقرب
من خمسه عشر مليون اغنيه مختلفه تدفع
لمستخدمي خدماتها عندما يستمع الناس
للمقطوعه التي صمموها ونشروها عبر منصات
بث الموسيقى
من سبوتيفاي اعلنت
الحساله بالفعل عشرات الالاف من اغاني
الذكاء الاصطناعي التي نشرتها بومي على
منصتها وحاليا تقود حمله ضد الحسابات
الوهميه التي تضخم عدد المستمعين لاغاني
بعينها استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي في تصميم
الموسيقى والاغاني ليس جديده لكنه الان
يشهد نشاطا ويتميز بدق مخيفه اليوم مثلا
لا يمكن لاي شخص مثلا ان يصمم اغنيه بصوت
مطربه المفضل
واقف
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا نائب رئيس شركه
انغامي محمد العقيلي اهلا محمد مرحبا صباح
الخير
نفرق ما بين الموسيقى اللي بنستخدم فيها
التكنولوجيا ولكن هي من صنع البشر كيف هاي
وكيف الموسيقى ذكاء الاصطناعي اللي ما
فيها تدخل بشري صح اليوم صار في تقريبا
ميكس بين الاثنين يعني الواحد مع الوقت ما
عاد يصير يقدر يخلق موسيقى بلا ما يستعمل
تكنولوجي الاجدد اللي هي اليوم
ادوات ادوات لصناع الموسيقى لا لكن هلا
المشكله الاساسيه اللي عم تصير هي
الموسيقى يلي ميه بالميه ذكاء الصناعي
اللي هي عم تخلي العالم يخلقوا موسيقى
بشكل ضخم بس هي بنفس الوقت ما بالمستوى
تبع الموسيقى اللي انتاج البشر هلا
الاسلوب اكيد بتقل
يختلف هل هي اعتقد يسمونها مازوره
بالموسيقى هل هي سرقه او كوبي هي عمليا
الصناعي يستعمل
مكتبه ضخمه من كل شي موسيقى موجوده
بالعالم ليتعلم منها كيف يخلق الموسيقى
تبعه هلا هذا الشيء مفيد للموسيقيين لانه
الموسيقى بدل ما ياخذ ساعات ليخلق التون
اللي بده اياها او الفقره اللي بده اياها
بالغنيه يستعمل
وهذا استعمال واقعي وحقيقي ومفيد جدا
النويز اللي عم بيصير اوضاع اللي عم بصير
من هي الموسيقى اللي هي هول الاصوات
الصغيره
عم تستعمل بس لتطلع اسمعوها العالم لحالها
وهي ما فيها اي اي نوع من فن فيها لوحده
المشكله الثانيه هي اللي اليوم الفنانين
وشركات الانتاج خايفين منها هي سرقه
الاصوات اللي هي انه امكانيه انه الواحد
يسرق صوت موسيقي ويطبق عليه غنيه مختلفه
تماما هذا الشيء ناخذ صوت شاكيرا مثلا
ونخليها تغني عربي
بكل سهوله
من فتره طلعت غنيه على كل المنصات بما
فيها انغامي هي غنيه لويك اند رودريك
بصوتهم فنانين مشهورين جدا بس هن ما غنوها
هو في حدا راح سرق اصواتهم واستعملهم
انتاج غنيه هذا الشيء اليوم بخوف الفنانين
هل صعب انه احنا كبشر نميز انه هاي من
انتاج وهاي انتاج بشري صعب احنا على فكره
محضرين
اغنيه او مقطوعه موسيقيه واحنا بدنا نحاول
نحظر عن جد ما عنا اي فكره
الحقيقه لا خلينا نشوف يلا
أنا جلابيه
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
لا يسامحك على انا سامع صوت جماله يقول
يعني
[موسيقى]
هييجي بحق شيرين
حقيقي حقيقي شفتي كتير منك
انا اقول لك ما ادري انا
ما ادري احس انه في عندها
يعني
انا اللي
الصحيح انها مش حقيقي
طيب يلا شنو المقطع الثاني سمعونا
[موسيقى]
العزف حقيقه ولا مش حقيقي حقيقي
انت هيك برايك كيبورد
[موسيقى]
عزف حقيقي انا وسام انا بقول لهذا العزف
حقيقي حقيقي طلعنا
اللي بعده يلا
بعده اكيد ما ادري
لا اعتقد مش حقيقي
كتير سمبل بسيطه
انا بقول حقيقي يا وسام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب خليني اسالك سؤال بانه اليوم هناك من
يقول بانه حتى المقامات او الموسيقى هي
عباره عن ارقام ثلاثه على اربعه الى اخره
فبالتالي بيعلم بحسبه من الممكن ان تنتج
موسيقى حتى لو لم تكن موسيقيه هي فقط
الاحساس يختلف هل يستطيع او تستطيع تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ان تنتج لنا موسيقى
ومقطوعه باحساس ما هي الاحساس ياتي من
الشخص اللي عم ينتج الموسيقى
فيك تنتج موسيقى وانك تلعب على البيانو او
تنتج موسيقى على مثل
موزع مثلا بالنسبه للابداع ياتي من
الاحساس يعني كيف راح يقول لهذا الذكاء
الاصطناعي انه اخلق لي هذا الجوله انا
بحاجه الى انه عرب
مثل ما اليوم بالرسم بالصور اللي عم يصير
اليوم انا ما بعرف ارسم لكن بعرف فكر
وابدع بشو شكل الرسم واتخيل بيخليني انتشر
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو اهم شيء انه راح يعني
يريحني من ماجد ابراهيم وعزف ماجد ابراهيم
زميلنا كتير حلوه شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا
يعطيك العافيه سعدنا بهذا الفقره معاك
محمد العقيلي شكرا لنائب رئيس شركه انغامي
شكرا لك لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات